Hi! This video focuses on the /i/ sound.
/i/ is a front vowel sound.
It is the closest or the highest front vowel sound.
To make the /i/ sound, you need to direct the front of your tongue up toward the hard palate while you are making the sound.
Notice how the front arches up while the tip stays down.
/i/
Most often the challenge with the /i/ sound is using it in place of /e/ or /a/.
So for example, beat can become bit or bet.
Practice along with me with the sentences and work to find your precision in each of the vowels.
Here we go.
She wants to sit in that seat.
There are some sheep on that ship.
At least let's make a list.
They are mean men.
That hairy beast is best.
I found a bead in her bed.
Be sure to try some more practice on EnglishCentral and good luck!